Yeah.
You Josh Gates.
Oh good.
Josh,
ask me an easy question.
Young suggested that the Christian Myth
failed to articulate Christ descended
into hell and that this resulted in
the mass shadow projection of the West.
Thoughts?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm going to refer to my book again.
I talked about this and rule seven,
pursue what is meaningful,
not what is expedient.
In that Chapter I discussed there's this
idea in Christianity that Christ took
the sins of the world onto himself and
I think that's very much related to the
idea of descent into hell.
They're not exactly the same thing,
but I,
but I'm going to address the first one
and it will shed light on the second.
So what does it mean that
the Messiah is archetype Lee?
The figure who takes the sins
of the world onto himself,
what it means practically speaking
or psychologically speaking.
And I've tried this with some of
my clients who were very naive.
It means to read the history of the world
as if you were the perpetrator of the
evils that you read about instead of
the victim or the noble intervener.
You know,
I talked to somebody the other day
about the movie Schindler's List and
Schindler was this German industrialist
who saved a very large number of Jews
that were in danger of well endanger of,
of,
of the final solution.
And one of the things he said was,
well,
you know,
when people watch Schindler's list,
they always think they'd be Schindler
and on if they don't think they'd be
Schindler,
maybe they think they'd be the
Jewish victim of the Nazis,
but they almost never think that
they'd be the Nazi persecutor.
And that's a big mistake because
when you read about history,
then you're reading about you,
even if the you is the perpetrator.
And unless you understand that,
then someone else has
to be the perpetrator.
And if someone else is the perpetrator,
well then you have a devil that
you can chase and you know,
maybe you've identified the devil properly
because you know now and then it's
like John Wayne Gacy or Ted
Bundy or someone like that.
And you've actually,
you know,
you've identified the perpetrator.
But so often,
okay,
far too often
the best way to constrain the
malevolence outside is to constrain the
malevolence within.
And so if you don't have a locale for
the evil of the world and you have to
externalize it because the evil
of the world certainly exists now,
it's a better solution to assume that your
fully capable of the terrible things
that people have been capable of throat,
the history of humanity,
and to contend with that genuinely.
And there's massive advantages to that.
I mean,
first of all,
it can actually produce and remarkable
increment self esteem because you know,
if you're just a rabbit and you
freeze whenever a wolf looks at you,
then you're just a frozen
rabbit and that's not so good.
You're just a scared rabbit.
But maybe you learn one day that
you're not a rabbit that you like,
you're actually quite the damn monster
and you've got teeth and you could really
use them in an underhanded
and horrible way.
This is why people like anti hero movie
so much hay because they go and see the
villains,
the mafia guys and these tough guys
and they antiheroes that populate our
imagination and think,
oh yeah,
well I'd really read it like
to be someone like that.
And the thing is,
is that being useless and week,
it's better to be a monster
then to be useless and weak.
And that's because being useless and
weak makes you a worst monster then a
monster.
That's why it's not like
being a monster is good,
but weak,
useless monster is the worst kind of
monster because that's a sort of monster.
A little jump in the dark and sink its
teeth into the back of your neck instead
of confronting you
forthrightly in the alley.
And so if you start to see yourself
as the perpetrator of historical
malevolence,
you know,
if you can imagine yourself
as an Auschwitz camp guard,
if you see yourself as,
as the,
the,
the vicious villain of the human story,
then all of a sudden you've got a lot
more respect for yourself and you can
unlock that internal monster
and not internal monster.
And then maybe you can tame the
damn thing or at least bring it in,
bring it into some sort of
partnership with yourself.
And then when someone pushes you around,
you can let a little bit of that out in
your eyes just a little bit and you can
say it would be better for you.
And for me if you didn't continue to
do that and you can actually mean it.
And then actually it will stop because
if you let a little bit of that out when
you tell someone to stop,
the probability that they'll
stop is extremely high.
And then just a tiny like vision of the
monster you could become is enough to
keep order in your house.
Hey,
and maybe in your state.
And so the mass shadow
projection of the West,
well,
you know,
here's another thing.
So one of the things the
Christians figured out was that,
um,
the snake in the garden
of Eden was also Satan.
I can't get into that.
It's too complicated.
You'll have to read chapter seven if you
want a full explication of that idea.
I,
that's as good an answer as to
the question as I can manage.
Tonight,
I spent all day,
let's see,
all day.
I got up at seven and I worked all day
till five on this video I told you about.
So I made about 400 anets
or something like that.
So I'm a little bit on
the burnt outside tonight,
so.